why
so the morlocks first appeared an
uncanny x-men issue number 169 and with
the first introduction of the Morlocks
the story turns out to be pretty
straightforward there really is no
reference point in terms of us jumping
to a previous event what we see with
this story is that we pick up with again
the girlfriend of Warren Worthington
Kandy southern and Kandy southern has
arrived back at the apartment of Warren
Worthington only to find that Warren
Worthington has vanished
she doesn't know where he is but when
she looks around the apartment she
notices that of course some of his
feathers are lying about and there's
also some blood indicating that maybe
there was a conflict that led in him
being taken against his will to some
other location in addition she also
realizes that there's somebody moving
around the apartment although she
doesn't know who it is but because she's
currently trapped upstairs she goes to
the phone and uses the speed dial to
contact Professor Charles Xavier
she tells Charles Xavier that
something's gone wrong that somebody's
taken Warren Worthington but before she
can elaborate to much further she's I
guess surprised from behind by a man who
calls himself sunder and tells her that
he's explicitly here to hurt her after
this we switch to Charles Xavier as he
contacts a I guess a Nightcrawler and
Nightcrawler of course is spending time
with a romantic interest of his own but
when he's telepathically informed by a
Charles Xavier that someone's taken
Warren Worthington and they've
presumably taken him somewhere
relatively close around there
Nightcrawler immediately takes off and
uses the time to try to recon the
immediate area to see whether or not he
can spot Warren Worthington he's
successful in locating Warren he's
apparently being taken down into a sewer
but before Nightcrawler can again
continue to investigate and follow the
group that's taken Warren Worthington he
is surprised by the fact that candy
southern is being thrown out of a window
and so he has to divert his attention to
candy southern in order to save her life
from here we transitioned to the rest of
the x-men that are inside the apartment
of Warren Worthington or I'm sorry about
Nightcrawler that are also doing what
they can to comfort candy southern and
again this is the reason why we hit
back on the events that led up to the
formation of x-factor
and the current state of the x-men
because during this time x-factor is
still off doing its own thing and so
Beast Iceman Bobby Drake Cameron Hodge
Jean Grey they're all off doing their
own separate situation and so that's the
reason why we don't see them here but
what we are joined with is Nightcrawler
is a colossus Kitty Pryde storm and what
they're doing is they're trying to plan
a course of action they're trying to
figure out what it is they're going to
do with regards to a Warren Worthington
but as time progresses the group decides
to to go after warrant and Warren to
attempt a rescue of some sort and this
leads them down into the sewer system
but as they progress further and further
into the sewers through the subways and
so on they're eventually ambushed by a
group of mutants now over the course of
this they're able to make their escape
but in the process Kitty Pryde is lost
she somehow ends up becoming separated
from the group but while she's separated
from the group she comes into contact
with a person named plague now plague is
a name that I would really like for you
to keep in the back of your head and the
reason why is because while the Morlocks
play background roles following this
story the their introduction and the
mutant Massacre plague will become one
of the original Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse and so it's very important
that we keep this trend going in terms
of remembering this particular character
as well as Caliban who we'll see later
on
but from here we switch back to the
x-men as they're continuing about their
their investigations but ultimately they
come into contact with the group of more
launched proper and when they come into
contact with this group we of course see
that the group is being led by a person
named Callisto now what Callisto tells
the x-men is that she is kidnapped
Warren Worthington for the purpose of
taking him as a mate somebody that can I
guess live alongside her as an equal in
terms of her perspective now Colossus
original idea here is that maybe she did
this out of love but storm says no the
storm says that this was done out of
desire that because Callisto doesn't
really even know Warren there's no
possible way that she could say she's in
love with him it's simply just the she
desire desires in equals she does
tires are made now initially the x-men
take it upon themselves to confront the
the Morlocks and to begin the process of
fighting the Morlocks but again
individual was like Colossus are a
little hesitant here and in fact
Colossus goes as far as to say that he's
pulling punches that he doesn't
necessarily want to injure any of the
Morlocks he doesn't want to hurt them
because as far as he knows they're doing
this against their will that they don't
really know what it is they're engaging
in that perhaps they've been duped or
they've been tricked by kalisto from
here as events progress and the
introduction of the Morlocks we
transition over to issue number 170 and
with issue number 170 we again continue
this story we of course had previously
seen that she was in that Kitty Pryde
was in turn rescued by Caliban and
Caliban of course is one of the Morlocks
and a mutant with the ability to sense
the location of other mutants but
Caliban also has a romantic interest and
Kitty Pryde and so with this story we
pick up his Kitty Pryde as she's coming
to as she's realizing that perhaps she's
in some location but she doesn't know
exactly what it is that's going on here
eventually it's revealed to her that
Caliban has rescued her and her
intention is to a have Caliban take her
to the location of the other x-men so
that she can attend to help rescue them
but as time progresses again the x-men
are continuing their conflict and during
this process storm is touched by plague
and because storm is touched by play
play tells the x-men that storm will
simply just be sick for a temporary
amount of time but that if plague
touches her again that storm will die
and so while the x-men have Callisto
subdued plague says that if the X been
released Callisto the plague will not
kill storm of course because the x-men
are for the most part benign in nature
and that they don't want to kill anybody
of course the x-men release Callisto
from here Callisto takes the x-men
prisoner and of course Caliban seeing
that Kitty Pryde is beginning to uh
succumb to her illness takes Kitty Pryde
to plague in the hopes the plague will
be able to cure Kitty Pryde of the
illness that is killing her but when
Colossus who of course at this time has
an interest in in Kitty Pryde sees that
she's injured he immediately goes into
an enraged state of course turning into
his organic metal form once again he
free of his bonds and tells the morlocks
that if anything should happen to kitty
pryde that he will kill them from here
what we see is that again as things
progressed storm is informed that the
only way for her to become free of her
situation to escape the orders of
Callisto is for her to defeat Callisto
in combat now also Nightcrawler here is
this and the initial idea is that
Nightcrawler is going to be the one to
fight Callisto to to freak a pride and
the rest of the x-men but storm tells
him no the storm says that because she's
the leader of the x-men and Callisto is
a leader of the Morlocks it's only
proper that storm be the one that fight
Callisto for for control of the Morlocks
and so of course we see that both storm
and Callisto engage in in combat and
Callisto sets the terms by saying that
storm cannot use any other powers and so
as the two of them begin to fight it
seems as though maybe Callisto's gaining
the upper hand but almost immediately
storm is successful in defeating
Callisto and so this brings a situation
whereby storm as the leader of the x-men
is also the leader of the Morlocks and
using her power she tells of course the
x-men to retreat and to free - free
Warren Worthington and they travel back
to back to the x-men or back to their -
the Xavier Institute and of course I
guess release Warren Worthington back to
x-factor now from here the the Morlocks
are going to remain somewhat of a
background theme they're going to appear
sporadically periodically within the
Marvel Comics but it won't be until the
mutant Massacre story that we will see
the Morlocks rise to prominent
prominence once more and become a
mainstay within the the Marvel Comics
universe
so following the morlocks first
appearance an uncanny x-men issue number
169 in 1983 Marvel followed up three
years later in 1986 with a story called
the mutant massacre now the mutant
massacre was a huge event and the realm
of Marvel Comics first and foremost it
was big because it was the first time we
had ever seen a crossover involving all
of the x-men related titles x-men X
Factor the new mutants but what Marvel
had also done with the mutant Massacre
is they had brought and Thor now as far
as I can tell the reason why Marvel had
done this despite the fact that Thor was
not part of the of the x-men or any of
the x-men related teams was because
Marvel was a little unsure as to whether
or not this gamble would pay off Marvel
was dumping a lot of resources they were
in effect throwing in the new mutants
that are throwing in x-factor they were
throwing in x-force Chris Claremont
Louise Simonson these were all going
into the efforts of creating this
crossover event but Marvel didn't know
if a crossover between Louis Simonson
and Chris Claremont would be enough to
draw readership and so by including Thor
one of Marvel's most prominent
characters Marvel was going to basically
reach out to those who weren't
necessarily familiar with the x-men
where x-factor related titles and give
them a reason to come into the situation
and to read this crossover event in
addition with the mutant Massacre we
also saw the introduction of gambit in
terms of why it was he was involved in
this now gambits introduction with the
mutant Massacre wouldn't come until some
years after the mutant Massacre event
but Marvel used the mutant Massacre as a
way to explain gambits existence in the
Marvel Universe at that particular point
in time of what Marvel did here is they
basically said that gambit had been
duped into initiating or I guess leading
the mutant Massacre although at the time
when the comic was originally published
gambit hadn't been created and so he
wasn't it wasn't part of the mutant
Massacre event but what Marvel had done
here with this story is they had
instigated a scenario with the Marauders
a group that was later revealed to have
led by by sinister into injuring one of
the Morlocks and then following that
Morlock back to the New York tunnels
when they found the location of where
the Morlocks were hiding at the
Marauders began the the conquest of
killing all the Morlocks off later on
the x-men x-factor the New Mutants and
Thor joined but what we saw with their
involvement here is that very rarely
they cross paths that is to say the
x-men were in the tunnels the x-factor
was in the tunnels New Mutants was in
the tunnels and Thor were in the tunnels
but x-men and x-factor never crossed
paths they didn't know the other was
there and so while their losses were
fairly substantial the Morlocks of
course were even worse but in the end
they were able to save a portion of the
Morlocks from a total extermination now
when cable issue number 28 Marvel began
the process of revealing to us that
perhaps mr. sinister had a hand in the
Morlock Massacre because again at this
time we didn't know why this had
happened during Chris Claremont entire
run of the x-men it was never explained
why the Morlock Massacre had taken place
it had simply just happened and it had
come to an end now at the end of the
more like Massacre story Psylocke had
looked into the mind of a saber-tooth
and believed that maybe there was a
hidden hand behind this but again this
shadowy figure this hidden hand was
never revealed in cable issue number 28
during a conflict with Sugarman a
sinister had observed Sugarman and
seeing that perhaps there was some
instance of of Sinister's own genetic
manipulation in Sugarman himself and all
sinister did was touch back on the idea
of eliminating those whose genetic
imprint could be found within both
sinister and these individuals a common
trait now after the Age of Apocalypse
event Marvel retcon all of this and what
Marvel did is they came back and said
that the Morlocks were the result of
tampering at the hands of dark beasts
the Age of Apocalypse version of beasts
who had managed to escape the timeline
but of course again this is simply just
one of these instances where by Marvel
makes things a little confusing and with
the Morlocks Marvel could afford to do
this because again the Morlocks while
they appeared in some significant
stories were never top billing they were
always background characters and 2001
Marvel had expanded on this a little bit
and they had released a series called
Morlocks which showed us that there were
other Morlocks around the world with
uncanny x-men issues a number 397 to 399
Marvel had given us a story whereby we
saw again other Morlocks in London but
for the most part Marvel kept the
Morlocks relegated to background
characters Marvel would simply just show
us that the Morlocks were still in
existence but there were never really
any major events involving them now the
closest that we got to a huge event
aside from the mutant massacre was in
2005 during the decimation story the
event that took place after the house of
M which dealt with the fallout of of the
mutant population with only 198 being
able to retain their powers and with
this all we really saw was that Caliban
was one of the Morlocks who would travel
back to the Xavier Institute to seek
refuge to seek protection from humans
who would attempt to eliminate what was
left of the mutant population we also
saw during the event called son of M
where by Quicksilver had traveled to the
inhuman city of Attilan and captured the
Terrigen crystals in order to bring
people's powers back had used Callisto
as the first person to have her powers
reinstated of the mutants who had lost
their abilities but because Callisto had
the ability to I guess have enhanced
senses the Terrigen crystals had sent
her powers and to overdrive and had
effectively made her go insane and so of
course we saw magneto arrive and take
Callisto away in order to help her cope
with her abilities as well as regain her
sanity but again this is just another
instance where by Marvel had simply
appeared and told us that the Morlocks
were still around they just simply
weren't part of any huge stories now in
terms of the Age of Apocalypse the
reason why we're again talking about the
Morlocks is because while the Morlocks
were not part of the Age of Apocalypse
event properties to say the 1995 event
Marvel came back in 2005 and they did a
ten-year anniversary for the Age of
Apocalypse and they showed us the
expanded universe of the Age of
Apocalypse the that timeline that
involved more than the initial groups
that we had seen during the 1995
then and among these groups we saw the
Morlocks and the Morlocks were expanded
upon they were given more information in
terms of our perception of them but
again this is just another example of
them being relegated to the background
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace